[Music]
alright people were taking a break from
politics this week and we're gonna focus
on the f-word that's right
food they say you are what you eat and
if that's true a lot of us are half hot
dog half pizza and half ice cream I know
that that's three-halves but we're a
pretty fat group of people these days
every week there's a new diet to follow
a new oil to avoid or a new superfood
that'll change your life then the week
after that we usually find out that the
new revolutionary diet will actually
make you gain weight you actually need
that oil to live and the superfood does
absolutely nothing and an endless slew
of magazines to the countless websites
and blogs devoted to keeping you
clicking on the newest fad and it
becomes almost impossible to figure out
what you should eat as those of you who
follow me on social media know I'm in
the midst of a little diet myself right
now
I'm doing a slow carb paleo diet which
is a slightly modified version of what
former Rubin Report guests Tim Ferriss
helped popularize basically I'm eating
only meat fish and veggies with no sugar
and very limited carbs I'm even putting
grass-fed butter in my coffee to get an
extra boost of fat and energy in the
morning as of taping this direct message
I've lost about 5 pounds in 10 days
although I've also punched four random
strangers on the street for looking at
me the wrong way but as they say
everything in moderation of course what
you should or shouldn't put in your body
isn't just about weight it's also about
your mind and this is a place where the
science is actually pretty solid the
foods that we eat or don't eat can have
a tremendous effect on our brain itself
right down to our ability to think as
we've seen a spike in degenerative brain
diseases such as Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's disease which are just two
of the many forms of dementia it's
becoming clearer and clearer that
fueling our brains with the right foods
and avoiding the wrong ones are a key to
brain health so much of what we talk
about on this show is related to clear
and critical thinking well we may not
think about how the food that we eat is
affecting our brains on a daily basis
feeding our brains the right foods is as
important actually possibly more
important than feeding our brains the
right information so this week we're
going to learn
some information on what we should feed
our brains so that we're optimized to
engage in intellectual battles in the
best way possible joining me to discuss
this is an old friend of the show and
author of the new book genius foods max
Luger veer now excuse me while I put
grass-fed butter on an avocado sprinkled
with goji berries
[Music]